all right the new hit film sound of
freedom is taking the country by storm
it has quickly now become a box office
hit while exposing the horrors of child
sex trafficking at the end of the film
they featured these shocking statistics
take a look at these take a second to
read them now this is a topic we have
been covering for years for example our
very own Sarah Carter has shared the
stories of human trafficking at a
southern border she sat down with the
human Smuggler last summer who told her
even he is uncomfortable with the amount
of children being smuggled into our
country our border is broken children
are being sexually abused nobody seems
to care in Joe Biden's white house
because open borders is facilitating all
of this look at this disturbing story
out of Tennessee soccer coach charged
with raping multiple miners was in this
country illegally for decades right now
with the reaction to sound of Freedom as
actor Jim Caviezel who by the way this
is separate and apart from sag and after
and all the the the strike that's going
on I want to make that a point that
you're not in any way going against that
is that correct yes those are my
brothers and sisters of sag I support
them but we're not a part of the am PTP
we wanted to be but they wouldn't didn't
want any part of this film
well here's the thing this film was made
but over five years ago it's based on a
true story and uh in your first week out
uh you blew away the new the new version
of Raiders of the Lost Ark with Harrison
Ford your second week you did better the
37 increase in theaters and you have far
less theaters than all these other
movies over your first weekend that
means to me Jim Caviezel and we've been
friends a long time that word of mouth
is is echoing all across the country I
found this to be a powerful movie that
everybody needs to see
Sean I just want to also thank you and
the American people for uh coming out
and supporting this film you were one of
the first that uh addressed this with us
and really helped get the word out
um you know when we were down in
Cartagena uh they guys would come up
traffickers and they were you know right
in front of us ask us if they want we
wanted ninjas or ninos and little little
boys or little girls and people think
that that's not something that happens
here in the United States will
absolutely it does over 300 000 children
under the ages of 18. we're sucked into
the deepest recesses of hell and it's
disgusting that the media hasn't covered
it like they should the there obviously
is really good media like yourself but
others that are completely ignore it and
I think people need to understand
American people are are are starting to
understand what is actually going on and
um are sick and tired of it especially
with the South border
I I mean it's amazing I think your
budget was 14 million I think the budget
to uh the latest Raiders movie was
somewhere near what two 300 million
dollars and you beat them handily both
weekends uh it's the true story of Tim
Ballard a former Department of Homeland
Security agent who who literally left
his job gave up his pension to go into
the business of rescuing these children
that are either sex slaves or in slavery
in some way shaped manner reformed by
the cartels I mean every rescue his life
is on the line and and you portray this
perfectly in the movie
yeah I get to play an absolute real uh
bona fide hero in Tim Ballard he you
know did everything that you read about
in the gospels where he essentially like
the the character I play Jesus and the
passion uh he he tells us you know kind
of the popular movie too that you played
yeah
twice a year at least
um
but he he sold everything he had to go
down there and to find that one precious
uh Pearl which is this little girl and I
think Americans understand that they
also have precious pearls in their
children and they don't want them taken
and they're looking at the government
now going what are you doing what are
the three agents letter agencies doing
they're not doing their job especially
when 85 000 children across the border
this last year and disappeared where did
they disappear to
yeah what very well said I want to
remind people this is all part of Angel
studiosangel.com if I'm not mistaken and
they had the hit series The Chosen about
the life of Jesus I I was riveted by all
four episodes that have come out and his
only son the story of Abraham in the
Bible the studio is taking I I think
it's the future of movie making I may be
wrong uh you guys are doing phenomenal
work and I I hope people will go see the
sound of Freedom this weekend I it will
open your eyes and people need to know
this evil exists Jim Caviezel thank you
for a great job great movie hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else